in unsere inspiration of the week geht
es dieses mal um selbst liebe love is
the key to more love in general das ist
das motto der influenza im rebecca auf
ihrem instagram account versucht sie das
thema selbst liebe mit fotos und videos
zu verdeutlichen
dabei geht es in erster linie darum sich
genau so zu akzeptieren wie man ist sie
möchte aber auch für mehr rollers und
reality of social media sorgen so die 28
jährige vor drei jahren fing sie an als
eine art selbsttherapie sich sechs
monate lang nicht zu rasieren
was selbst liebe für sie bedeutet hat
sie uns exklusiv erzählt hallo mein name
ist rebecca auf meinem account spreche
ich ganz viel über das thema selbst
lieber weil ich glaube dass alles bei
uns selbst denkt was viele für mich für
mich selbst lieber ganz viel also
einerseits dass ich für mich da bin in
guten sowie in schlechten zeiten wenn es
mir schlecht geht dass ich mich auch in
den arm nehme ich meine gefühle zu
lassen und zwar bevor angels alle
emotionen dass ich für mich darin
einfach das sind alles für uns selbst an
menschenleer merkel selbst liebe zu
schenken nicht selbst mit liebevollen
augen zu betrachten
und ja eben diese liebe in mir zu
trainieren dann kann ich auch viel mehr
liebe in unserer welt kriegen
und genau das brauchen wir brauchen viel
mehr liebe auf unsere welt fähre wer
besondere lebensweise bekommt sie aber
nicht nur positives feedback wie sie
dabei trotzdem ihr mainz hat behält
erklärt so ganz viele bier also
jahrelange praxis von einem positiven
mindset wo mir zum beispiel meditation
extrem geholfen habt achtsamkeit übungen
yoga mich mit der natur verbinden focus
angebot ist auch etwas was kann ich mich
immer wieder erinnere nicht angeboten
mich an den guten willen zu orientieren
wenn man verliert sich geändert in einen
negativen gedanken und in diesem huster
und dann sucht man das problem an sich
lediglich auf das positive zu
konzentrieren
und wie ich mit hass kommentar also
online sage ich immer blog komplex im
sinne von ich blockiere weil die meisten
sich einfach nur auskotzen wollen und
das habe ich ganz ehrlich habe kann ich
habe besseres zu tun sei nur so und ich
verabschiede mich von diesen menschen in
dankbarkeit und wünsche ihnen nur das
beste aber wieder sozusagen abbauen
touris also grenzen was super wichtig
ist nein zu sagen ja im echten leben
habe ich schon noch gerne diskussionen
und vielleicht auch ja mal
aufklärungsarbeit aber ich merke auch
wenn wo ein stopp ist also wenn jemand
das gefühl gibt nicht gut genug zu sein
nicht schön genug nicht smart genug oder
was auch immer nicht genug
dann verabschiedet sich einfach von
diesen menschen sorgt
[Musik]